oops
all right damn it
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
welcome back to
yo
absolutely favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
ripping with griffin
you know how we do
i like doing it live so i got to do a
lot of work because a lot of times i'm
by myself but it don't matter
welcome to the podcast
um this week what are we talking about
uh we still you know
will smith got banned 10 years
uh the nba playoffs to here i'm big on
that and then i'm gonna do one of my
spoiler reviews beginning the end of the
movie of this movie i just saw last
night called the lie
but other than that
welcome back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right and we're here we're from with
griffin back again thank you for being
here
but before we get started
before we get started let's pay some
bills y'all coinbase
coinbase do you identify as crypto
curious
if you thought about entering the world
of cryptocurrency but it felt a little
you felt overwhelmed
coinbase makes it
easy to learn and buy for a limited time
new users can get 10
in free bitcoin when you sign up today
at coinbase.com
riffin
griffin
point coinbase.com riffin griffin y'all
wait how do i get rid of this
there we go
okay welcome to the show
um
let's see what else is going on here you
know as always thanks for being here
um
make sure you subscribe
you know what i mean
hit the subscribe
you know
uh
and also i'm on twitch
every day
air griffin gaming come check me out
playing that duty
my call of duty i love playing call of
duty so check me out on that y'all
and as always too make sure you um
[Music]
if you're so inclined i am i am i got
some videos almost ready to go
uh for my patreon so if you want to be
a patreon person hit me up on you know
the links in the in the bio there
you know patreon.com eric griffin be a
patreon member guys help support me and
i'm doing more content reviews real
world advice from a grown-ass man little
videos of me and rachel
just you know i'm out here trying to do
the thing the social media thing 50 year
old old man on the internet trying to do
his thing so help support if you'd like
and or you could just be a member or you
could be a youtube member too you can
also join to be a youtube member so if
you're a youtube member or patreon i put
those videos up so i have a couple
videos up now that only people that are
members or you can go to the patreon to
see them
but anyways uh thanks for being here oh
and let you know let's also do some
other business too guys i'm also gonna
be don't forget to check me out oh look
at that i'm gonna be at the houston
improv this weekend thursday friday
saturday houston improv so texas come on
out and see me this week i'm gonna be at
the houston improv so come check that
out
um let's see um
all right so what happened this week so
i was on the adam carolla show which
came out actually today uh i was i we
recorded yesterday so the adam corolla
show came out today i had a blast with
them
uh you know he's man he's one of the
og's right og original uh podcast people
so shout out to adam corolla and all the
crew that were there very very lovely
people and we had a we had fun time
talking about stuff
you know we you know we just talked
about a bunch of stuff and i i
appreciate adam corolla because i feel
like i i vibe with him
because he's got a really rational
approach you know and i don't think
people like to do i think people like to
jump to conclusions and people like to
fight and argue and if if you don't
agree you're wrong and i think that him
and i have a way of being like well you
know maybe there's another side to it
and then you know and i like i like
living in that space
so that was fun so shout out to the adam
crowler show so please go check me out
on that after you finish watching this
obviously and then i also heard big
shout out to howard stern who i've never
met i've never met the guy i've been on
the howard stern wrap up show quite a
few times when i was out in new york
which is also a big show
you know
and
they were he played my parts of my
standup routine about the will smith
chris rock situation
and he played that on the howard stern
show and gave me some praise and then
one of the guys chimed to him oh he's a
friend of the show he comes on you know
he's been on the wrap-up show so and you
know i got some praise from howard stern
so that was kind of cool man so shout
out to uh you know howard stern and the
crew and you know wow you know what i
mean
one of the giants in the
what do you say broadcasting podcast
world so that was really cool so uh yeah
man i don't know i'm feeling good today
right
feeling good today glad to be here and i
love doing it live so i appreciate you
guys uh being here you know and your
super chat and all that kind of stuff uh
if i got i want to give it also a shout
out to
i want to give a shout out to some one
of the fans man uh chris
chris you i never can pronounce his last
name so i'm not gonna try but chris you
he sent me some dope beats
so this guy
you know he he he sends dope beats and
i've gotten a lot of great music from
fans like dopapod who made my theme song
uh shout out to them they're a great
funk man and they you know they made
that song for me you know and so i'm
still using it today so shout out to
them but if you have a song if you're a
musician an artist and you want to send
it in so like when people send super
chats we're going to play some of chris
you
uh i never pronounced his last name so
we just call him chris you you know but
here's one of his songs
it's kind of funky you know what i mean
uh oh
what
no he didn't
it's starting off fresh
okay
i might need the singing mic
[Music]
sometimes
i
so send that super chat
if you wanna hear a rap
and if you listen in later
on spotify
apple podcast that's fly
wherever you get your podcast
eric griffin
all right anyways
so shout out to him and anybody else
that's got like a fresh beat
you got a fresh beat you want to see me
i use them a lot on my gaming channel
uh once again that's eric griffin gaming
twitch eric griffin gaming because
anytime i win a war zone match if i win
a good match then i play one of these
beats i got from the fans and then i do
like a you know freestyle thing over it
i'm 50. y'all it's a it's a it's a dad
thing right i'm not even a dad yet wait
till i become a dad
shout out also to my beautiful fiancee
rachel who um
she just signed
with wilhelmina models you know what i
mean still doing it 33 years old still
out here
walking this runway like a g
looking delicious as usual so let me
wait let's go to her page
let's go to rest let's go to rachel's
instagram page
um
you know what i mean
so she's out there you know
i mean damn y'all i don't even i can't
even believe
i can't even believe this is who i'm i'm
just look at this
you know what i mean look at her oh yeah
be jealous y'all be jealous
that was her walking in fashion week i
mean look at this
look how glamorous she looks on the
runway right so shout out to my
beautiful fiancee rachel
you know you got to do that y'all
because she fly
anyways
um
people don't you don't know what a super
chat is it's right there
super chat is just like a tip it's like
right there on the thing but whatever
and again also shout out to all the
apple podcasts spotify amazon music
wherever you listen to your podcast
thanks for listening to me every week
making me a part of your life okay so
anyways uh so here we are um what so
what happened this week that i wanted to
yip yap about i don't want to keep going
on about the will smith thing but some
new news is that the oscars actually
banned him for 10 years my feelings on
it i don't think it's enough i mean 10
years for a thing that like probably
only happens once every 10 years for
most people anyway right
it's not like you know you get nominated
for an oscar every single year it's a
rare feat that somebody's like that
that's a rarity but he is the kind of
guy that he's got to kind of cache if he
could do like a you know dramatic film
every single year if he wanted to next
thing you know you know so they banned
him for 10 years i don't think it's
enough has nothing to do with
necessarily him i just think that a
deterrent i think a bigger deterrent
should be like it should have been
longer 25 years or maybe even banned for
life
and the reason why i say that is because
if someone like that someone with that
sort of cachet someone with that sort of
reputation
could have a bad night and then flip out
you need to let everybody know it's not
okay
because
the night of they made it seem like it
was okay
and in retrospect they're looking back
like we did not handle that correctly so
they so moving forward they need to let
everybody else know if you having a bad
day don't show up
because if you do something stupid like
he did it's going to be serious
consequences i mean the only other other
thing they could have done too is like
taking this oscar away but i don't
believe in that because it's like when
they took reggie bush's heisman trophy
away he's still heisman winner to me you
know what i'm saying like
or even when they take it away an award
away for a good reason like i don't know
for all you young people you might not
know who this is but i don't know if
y'all remember millie vanilli uh who's
out there who's who's out there that
remembers millie vanilli you know and
and so they were this like big pop band
um
they were you know they were this big
pop band in in the um in the what do you
call it in the 90 i think they were in
the 90s i don't know if they were in the
90s or not you know i can't i don't
remember if it was in the 90s
uh
you know if y'all remember them
you know that's millie vanilli i think
one of them actually killed themselves
uh because of you know i pro i don't
know what it was but you know look they
might have but 30 years ago millivilli
returned their best new artist grammy
should they get their award back now
that's one of the things that's coming
out right now but they had that song you
guys remember that song
blame it on the rain
so that was like their big song and then
so
they you know it it came out later that
they weren't actually singing the songs
you know it came out that was like late
80s yeah so it came out later that they
actually
um
they actually
were lip syncing and it was someone else
singing and they but they were huge you
know what i mean like back then there
was no social media like i don't think
you could get away with that now i don't
think it's possible to get away with
something so blatant now because of like
the access we have with everything right
so they like you know
then it came out later
the the people who the the real singer
or whoever was behind it they probably
didn't get money or credit and they were
like wait a minute why are these clowns
getting all the credit and it's my voice
or whatever whatever happened i don't
remember the story it was so long ago
but okay
let me relate this to what i'm talking
about with the oscars and will smith so
so these guys won best new artist okay
so then they took it away from them when
they found out it was all fake but
my thing is like
you you still gave it to him
so regardless they were best new artists
so imagine you're like number two you're
the number two person and you were
putting your heart and soul it was pm
dawn at the time i remember pm dawn i
think pm dawn i think did i think they
got the ask the emmy i don't know
somebody looked that up
you guys be my jamie at home and look
that up and they put it in the uh
comments so
you know like so imagine you're like
runner up you're like number two
you know what i mean like
do you want to be like given that oscar
knowing that you lost out to
some people that like
didn't even really deserve it you know
what i mean like so
it's still tarnished no matter what so
anyway my point is
even if they would have taken it away
from him
we gonna remember to slap and actually
the slap is gonna help us remember even
more that he won best actor because
nobody remembers those things
you know a year out two years out but so
it's gonna be synonymous with that so
we're gonna remember we're always gonna
remember remember when will smith slap
chris rock
and then right there that memory is
going to be he also won the oscar so
you know you can't take it away from him
so i don't know i think the punishment
could have been harsher so
that's that
it is what it is
you know something else that uh i didn't
know about on this on the
the adam carolla show is this this actor
sam elliott you guys know that actor sam
elliott
you know he said he he made some
comments about
the the movie power of the dog which i
didn't know and he said some things that
hurt people and i feel terrible about
that i mean i don't know like
you know i don't know if apparently the
movie has some like there's some
gay stuff in it like but who cares right
i don't i don't care about that like
whatever
you know what i mean it's like it's like
china is always taking gay out of movies
as if there's no gay people in china
it's like this idea that like people
that hate gay it's like get over it you
know what i mean
this gay is everywhere you're gonna be
like i don't know when are we gonna just
accept that so just you kind of just go
okay you know what i mean let's just get
over it but anyways he made some comment
and i think
it was you know
um
like he said i told the wtf because he
was on mark maron's podcast i thought
jane champion was a brilliant director
and i want to apologize to the cast of
proud of the dog brilliant actors i
don't know like he apologized but i'm
not sure if he said something so
disparaging about
if he's if he
i need to know that he say something
about the movie
that was you know homophobic or anti-gay
i don't know if he said that or not like
i need to know did he say that or did he
just not like the movie and people are
inferring that that's why he didn't like
the movie and i was talking about this
on corolla like i don't like that
i don't like that like it should be okay
to not like something regardless of
who's in the movie or what it's about
like it's okay not to like hamilton
it's okay not to like black panther it's
okay
you could go to black panther and be
like i thought that was a of all the
marvel movies i thought that was one of
the worst
it is okay to say that you're not racist
if you say that if you're a nerd you've
established yourself as who you are
because that's how i that's how i am i
can go to a movie and like i just want
the artistic integrity i want to suspend
my disbelief i want to feel good about
this or or be moved and i don't care
about whatever the social agenda that's
being trying to be put out there by
other people what's the filmmaker trying
to put out there and if it doesn't go
well
then whatever because when you watch a
white movie whatever that means you know
what i'm saying you watch a movie that's
predominantly all white actors whatever
a genre piece or or if it even if it's
the lady gaga
brad bradley cooper movie right where
the stars are white and it's about white
people doing pretty white [ __ ]
you don't like it nobody's coming out
and being like oh you don't like it
because it's white that's not something
that it's out there but it's always that
when it's the other thing and i just
think we should be careful about that
so
sam elliott had to come out and
apologize
because he criticized the movie and i
you know people you know when some
grisly old cowboy guy with a big ass
mustache
says some stuff
you know people go uh oh i wonder if it
was because of you know what i mean so
we just got to be careful with that kind
of stuff man
we really
really
do
okay so let's get going in the podcast
but before we do that man let's go back
to our
great sponsor of the program
coin
base
so
i use coinbase and i remember when like
bitcoin litecoin was like five six years
ago i was with rick glassman by the way
i was with rick glassman in chicago and
we were we were like he was just passing
through and we were sitting in my hotel
room we ordered some food and he was
showing me crypto and i was like oh man
i just bought some litecoin and then it
just blew up and it was like so
fascinating i didn't know anything about
it and uh coinbase really helps with
that and so that was like some fun thing
and it's like it's remember it's extra
it's like if you know
look coinbase offers a trusted and easy
platform to buy sell and spend
cryptocurrency they support the most
popular digital currencies on the market
and make them accessible to everyone
they offer portfolio management and
protection learning resources and a
mobile app so you can trade securely and
monitor your crypto millions of people
in over 100 countries trust coinbase
with their digital assets for a limited
time new users can get ten dollars in
free bitcoin when you sign up today at
coinbase.com riffin griffin sign up at
coinbase.com
riffin griffin for ten dollars in free
bitcoin this offers for limited time
only so be sure to sign up today that's
coinbase.com
[Music]
okay
my people
let's get to
this other thing i want to talk about
i'm stalling because i have to go over
to my computer and do this and here we
go
nba play playoffs nba playoffs are here
y'all so if you don't want to listen to
sports this is your time to just jet
but
all right so i love
the nba and i think this year's nba
playoffs are going to be absolutely
outstanding
um it's been quite a tumultuous year
it's just just with
all of the big stories you know kyrie
irving not wanting to get vaccinated to
other players not getting vasquez not
being able to play in canada
the injuries the the
the mvp race uh the like the who's the
favorite who's gonna win uh the the just
the the matchups the people the the
disappointments the the ones that are
shining it's like it's really a
spectacular time for the nba and so
tonight is the first play in game so
you know i don't even know how this
works but so they started this playing
tournament so
apparently
so phoenix is like in the west phoenix
is the number one seed and so new
orleans plays san antonio and then the
the lakers play minnesota all right and
so the winner
i mean it's crazy how it works so the
winner of that goes here
the loser goes there
oh and and the a ac stays the eighth
stays the eighth seed okay so okay now i
understand the playing tournament so now
i'm understanding it okay so like see
that's what i was i thought that like
i actually thought that the seventh and
eighth seed had a chance to not make the
playoffs but now i realize if you're a
seventh and eighth seed you make the
playoffs regardless it's just about
deceding or is it
actually i don't even know actually
i guess you i guess there is a chance
that you're not going to make the
playoffs like how does this work
you know what i mean anybody really know
how this works somebody's got to explain
it to me in the comments
uh
this this is some crazy oh yeah lakers
play minnesota sorry lagos play
minnesota i mean clippers play minnesota
san antonio plays new orleans and so
okay so the winner of the 910 goes here
and then
the
winner of the clippers okay i see i see
so the winner of clippers minnesota
they become
the the seventh seed
got it
winner of clippers minnesota becomes the
seventh seed the loser of that game
has to play
the winner of
the nine and ten game which is new
orleans vs okay i get it now so nine and
ten play to move on so if you win that
game you play the winner of the i'm
sorry you play the loser of the 7-8 game
okay
i got it okay so that's and i actually
like to play in i don't know what you
guys feel about it you could tell me in
the comments but i actually liked the
playing game i like that i like it
because it keeps it interesting it keeps
a bunch of teams still viable for the
playoffs so i really like that okay so
that's pretty dope all right so you have
that so then and then you have and then
in the eastern conference all right so
you're gonna have atlanta's nine
uh charlotte's ten so the winner of that
plays the loser of brooklyn cleveland
okay
brooklyn cleveland so
uh and then the winner will be the
seventh seed or if they you know so all
eyes are on the nets right now to see uh
how that
debacle
get gets itself if they can get themself
right
all right so like
what's all that what's the big talk man
so you know in the in the west you got
phoenix phoenix who is now 64 and 18.
they have the best record they made it
to the championship last year and then
there was all that thing last year where
the lakers lebron got hurt and it was
the whole idea that like well if lebron
didn't get hurt or if the lakers didn't
have injuries they probably would have
beat phoenix so that was like the
thought so it kind of tarnished their
ride to the the the championship well
they proved all that wrong this year
because phoenix has the best record in
the league they have the best chance to
win the championship they're the
favorite to win the championship at 64
and 18. so shout out to chris paul who
got injured again but devin booker
stepped up and the phoenix suns still
have the best record so i think that
they have a team in place that even they
can come through injuries so look out
for phoenix would that be exciting i
don't know phoenix winning the
championship
i don't know but
i like chris paul a lot i've met him
quite a few times and i still go back to
my clipper days when he was with the
clippers and i really enjoy that so so
there's phoenix right so then you got
dallas right dallas at the four seed um
in that bracket so four first five
dallas versus utah i mean utah's been
slipping i just went to a clipper game
where paul george first gave back and
they put it on utah so i think utah is
in a rough spot right now i hope they
get their stuff together but dallas man
they looking good luca donches is now
he's skinnier he's slender he's taking
him more serious because he hasn't got a
long run in the playoffs yet because he
kind of tires out in the fourth quarter
but he's gotten himself in great shape i
mean they're professional athletes
that's what they're supposed to do so
shout out to dallas looks like that's
gonna be a good matchup so like if like
could dallas beat utah and then beat
phoenix whoo that'll be something else
right
so shout out to them and even these
playing tournament people like new
orleans pelicans like good for them
right new orleans pelicans even without
zion
just what they've done you know like the
lakers are ridiculous man trading away
all the people that they traded away i
think they should have kept all these
people with lebron and they might have
still won a championship but who knows
we'll get to the lakers all right so
then you got golden state at the third
seed uh they kind of fell off just a
little bit in terms of like going for
the best record because steph curry got
hurt and they're still trying to work uh
what's his name thompson back in clay
thompson and then draymond green got
hurt but they still managed to salvage
their season so now golden state is the
third seed so good for them right
and then you got denver with the joker
who is one of the mvp candidates but
like i can't i don't know man i just i
just think that they don't really have a
chance to win the championship i just
don't we're not not without their dude
what's his name um who's the guy to play
with the joker guys in the chat um
he hasn't played in like two years and
that dude is great one of the top 10
players in the league i just can't
believe i can't remember his damn name
but
they uh you know i just don't think they
really have a chance without because
they still got these injuries and and i
think someone else got injured on their
team too so i don't know if denver
really has a chance and then you have
memphis so memphis with uh uh what's
that what's the kid's name what's what's
the memphis kid uh that dude uh john
morant whoo that dude is good
he he's he's in the top five mvp
candidate and there's people picking
them as a dark horse to win the
championship they could win the west at
the very least
very good team they've been playing
great all year he's been injured as of
late but i'm sure he'll be ready for the
playoffs they already knew their seating
so they just said let's keep him out so
john moran is looking dope at the
memphis grizzlies so if it's memphis
grizzlies and phoenix suns in the east
in the west final i'm not be shocked or
golden state if it's golden state
phoenix that'll be a great matchup uh i
cuz i'd love to see chris paul and and
uh steph curry go at each other i love
that or even john moran being the young
new point guard versus chris paul the
old veteran savvy port guard about to be
37 years old so good job west so more
about the west like the lakers man what
a disappointment
just what an utter disappointment if
you're a laker fan uh i feel bad for
lebron james and i don't feel bad for
him but at the same times like lebron
james is like one of the greatest
players of all time you could argue
if you're a person that thinks lebron
james is the greatest player ever i'm
with you on your argument i have i have
nothing to say i'm a michael jordan guy
and you could be a lebron guy and we
could have a great fun at the uh
at the jamal murray that's the guy's
name thank you very much jamal murray uh
that's the denver guy so um
you know
the you know if you want to argue lebron
james is the greatest player of all time
you have a solid argument he went to 10
championships he won four being second
place is not a slight if you're telling
me that
he had 10 chances to be the champ and he
finished second or first that's pretty
damn good plus all of his accolades and
all of his statistical achievements
you have a solid argument
so it is what it is but this is a
disappointment it is an utter failure
and disappointment you got russell
westbrook you got lebron james anthony
davis carmelo anthony and a host of
players that are supposed to support
these guys and it just they did not get
the job done
and then i think russell bruss book took
too much blame
if you look at his statistics
it's pretty much on par with his whole
career
his statistics
his shooting percentage his turnovers i
think he has less tone overs this year
than he ever than he had last couple
years
and that's the thing people were getting
on him about like i think he took too
much of the blame i think lebron james
uh you know should take i think he
should come out publicly and be like yo
this was on me
we didn't do it but we're coming back
next year we're gonna get this right
because they're strapped with the salary
cap issues i don't i don't know how
they're gonna do it i don't know how
they're gonna do it but i i feel like
i feel like i have enough faith in
lebron james and i would not be
surprised at lebron 37 38 years old by
the way second in scoring at 37 years
old just a physical freak man
crazy so if they come back next year and
they practice in the off season and
maybe they decide to go you look at each
other and go yo we old and they doubtin
us let's do it but as if but of right
now that that was the most disappointing
failure of an nba season in the history
of the nba because their expectations
was championship and they let us all
down
so that's my lakers thing now let me
lastly talk about my clippers clippers
eighth seed clippers gotta beat
minnesota i mean we got to
you know this is ridiculous
but even if they don't they gotta win
the winner of they still can have a
chance they got to beat san antonio or
pelicans
uh my clippers
once again another disappoint like
la is full of like people that can't
stay healthy
like when is it when are we going to
realize with anthony davis that that
dude ain't never gonna be a hundred
percent i just
unless he goes into off-season with
lebron james and goes to that magic
doctor and wherever they go
whatever they have to do to make their
bodies work like that he needs to go do
what lebron james does
he could be like man i'm what is he 26
27 and here's this old man 10 years
older than him
out here giving it to the league
at that age
he's taking care of himself anthony
davis get on board with lebron james
program so you could come back and play
over 70 games and give this team a
chance to win same thing i feel about
with my clippers man paul george in and
out of the lineup now three years in a
row
kawhi leonard don't even get me started
kawhi leonard and his degenerative knee
disorder whatever that is that's what
they called it degenerate that means it
ain't gonna get better
i i just can we get one solid year out
of this dude
like the toronto like toronto maximized
the kawhi leonard experience and won a
championship
can the clippers do the same thing last
year was the year man i felt like with
kawhi leonard they would have beat
phoenix last year right but who knows
maybe not because phoenix is pretty good
but anyway my point is what's going on
man come on dude
come on kawhi i need you to get it
together man
i feel for the dude because it's like
you know
he could he he was like flirting with
being an all-time all-time great like
top five he had potential to be that
kind of player you know what i mean he
won winning championships in two
different cities and being the man on
the team but he just
always hurt man
he's on the all hurt team he's mount
rushmore of all hurt players
it's like him
grant hill
you know
uh anthony davis they probably like that
that's the all hurt starting lineup
and whoever else you guys can who else
can you guys think of in the in the in
the chat
put in the comments
who's someone like a all-time great
player that never maximized their
potential because they were always hurt
whoo
um
all right so that's that western
conference y'all that's the western
conference
so let's now go over to the east
okay
so over in the east
you got in the play-in tournament
it's the brooklyn nets at the seventh
seed
playing
cleveland the eighth seed that's going
on tonight
and then you got atlanta the 9th seed
playing charlotte the 10th seed oh
that's gonna be a good game
that's a good game right there that's
too you know
lay say what you want about uh what's
his name lamar ball
say what you want about him levar
whatever his name is lavar
the man
he got two
nba players that are really good and one
of them's like
like an all-star level you know and
still lonzo ball is balling man he's
like a point guards point guard and then
he got this kid you know his other kid
in uh charlotte so that's gonna be you
know him versus uh what's uh what's his
name um
the atlanta point guard i'm so old i'm
forgetting people's names all the time
i'm so sorry
uh trey trey young so that's gonna be a
good match up and then you got brooklyn
versus cleveland i think brooklyn should
win that game and just go on to play
boston in the in the first round which
is gonna be like like wow imagine you're
boston you got the second seed you
you've turned your franchise around with
all the stuff that's been happening in
the last few years and you get to play
you have to you get the nets in the
first round
whoo but there's a lot of things there
because kyrie left boston it's a lot of
subtext there it's a lot of like uh you
know jamal what's what's his name
what's his name brown and tatum
brown and tatum always get overlooked as
superstars so they got a lot to prove i
really want to see that match up next
verse um
nets verse boston
and then okay so you got miami as the
number one seed crazy they're another
team that has proven themselves to be
like hey you know we're pretty good you
know they were in the championship in
the bubble and it was kind of like we
were all giving them that like well it's
the bubble and they did it
they now they got the
number one seed so they're being
overlooked so that kind of sucks for
them
but imagine if like let's say the nets
lose tonight nets lose tonight and then
they play and then they make it to the
eighth seed and then they have to play
miami has to face the nets in round one
so
the nets man that's the whole thing man
that's that's that shit's crazy so you
got that
all right so then the other teams you
got philly who is going through some
deal things right now you got joel
embiid i think he should win the mvp
just of what he's done to keep that team
afloat all year james harden like is he
gonna show up man i've been talking
about this now for two years you know is
he gonna show up like kd
kyrie and james harden they all got some
stuff kyrie's on that all actually
kyrie's on that all injured team too man
he should have three championships the
first one with cleveland when they lost
when they to the golden state cleveland
would have waxed them with kyrie irving
he should have won last year
if he didn't get hurt because because
when when they were playing milwaukee
they were up 40 on them and then kyrie
got hurt that's that's just that would
have been his third championship and who
knows maybe even cleveland would have
went and won more because they had that
momentum so anyways so kyrie got
something to prove right and then you
got kevin durant who we all think was
weak when he went to golden state and
now last year you know he came he got
really injured he's trying to come back
from this he seems to be sustaining his
health right now i hope he maintains it
because he's bawling right now i mean
he's a talent you know what i mean
regardless of what i say about him he's
still a talent right so but can he carry
a team by himself basically be the man
and win a championship he's got that to
prove and then james harden who they
traded the world for to get him over to
you know
uh philly you got to deal can he finally
show up in the playoffs man
hey show up in the playoffs james harden
and then you got doc rivers who is the
most overrated coach in history
the most overrated coach in the history
of nba sorry and i love you doc
but if it wasn't for kevin garnett
being undeniable you would have been
you would have been fired like your
career had been over he got that one
championship off the backs of kevin
durant paul pierce and ray allen
doing the damn thing
but this guy he's lost 3-1 leads like
four times in the playoffs so he got
something to prove as a coach
so i love the eastern conference i just
love it i want to see who comes out of
there is it going to be philly here's
the people that really got a legit shot
they all have actually they all got a
legit shot philly
brooklyn
freaking milwaukee who at the third seed
they're balling they're showing
everybody too that now it wasn't a fluke
that we lost yes last year yeah they
were up 40 but we're still good we won a
championship so they trying to come back
and be back-to-back champs again you got
boston's story of them like revitalizing
the franchise the eastern conference is
the best right now okay
anyone these teams can win boston
milwaukee
philly outside shop miami even though
they're the number one seed and
and uh even toronto got a chance to
sneak in there like toronto could
actually beat philly in the first round
and thank you voyage eats for the
the super chat guys and that's a super
chat the guy said
a 19
super chat y'all
19 super chat so right in the middle of
the show
oh oh oh we going to the beach
thank you for the super chat
it wasn't white
thank you mac
19.99
eric griffin fine as wine
all right there we go
so tell me in the uh
uh i'd love to see in the chat the
people that are watching live who you
got in the championship who do you think
is coming out of the east who do you
think is coming out of the west and who
do you think is going to win let's get
those in the comments and then uh during
my patreon episode when i'm really going
in through the nba again
i'm gonna have uh we're gonna i'm gonna
read those comments and we'll see you
know how we're doing with that you know
so nba is looking good man i mean the
nba is looking good man as i look at
this again wait let me actually show you
guys as i look at this again man i mean
that's a good looking bracket dude good
looking bracket on the east i mean the
west is kind of like iffy we're not sure
who
who's going to do what you know memphis
golden state you know
it's going to stay really good remember
they have something to prove because it
was like the last time they won it was
because of k.d now he's gone like if
golden state should go out come out of
the west and actually win the
championship to me that nullify that
makes kevin durant look bet even worse
to me it just makes him look like yo
dude they could they did it without you
and they did it without you again so
they got something to prove in terms of
that so
whoo and then jason kidd shout out to
him over at uh for the coach in
got dallas relevant again you know even
with all the his baggage and stuff
that's going on with that so it's
looking good y'all it's looking good
all right
all right y'all
that's the uh nba talk
let me get this back up
that is the nba talk
um but now
i want to talk now this is something i
like to do
um
i like to do this on the podcast
uh this is my movie spoiler
okay
so
this is a movie spoiler so if you
actually want to watch this movie
you should thank you for watching with
griffin and you can leave now but if
you'd like to hear me recap a movie
that's what i'm about to do right now
and the movie's called
the lie
it's called the lie it was um
2018
it's rated r
uh the movie stars
peter
cyrus guard
i can't i never i'm terrible with names
but if you see him you know who he is
you know he's one of those guys that you
don't know his name but you see him
everywhere
same thing with uh the the this other
star let's just look at him because i'm
not gonna try to get the names right
this guy he was in batman you know what
i mean
that's that guy you know like you know
him when you see him you know what i
mean
you're like oh that guy and same with
this chick man she's in a lot of great
shows uh
wait no no that's not it
that's not her how can we oh no pick the
wrong person this lady right here
um her name is what how do you say her
name
my really i don't even know but she's in
a lot of great stuff too man she's been
in a lot of great shows like really
fantastic she's a really great actress
fantastic actress and then they also
it's also starring that young girl right
there
uh what's her name joey king
yeah she's dope
beautiful young girl
she's going to be one of those she's
going to be a starlet you know you know
she's just really great okay so
let's talk about the lie man the lie
oh i should you know what i should have
made just the background but i was i had
other stuff going on so i couldn't get
it done but anyways
so the lie
again spoiler alert so if you don't want
to hear okay so i i was just up i
couldn't sleep i threw it on and i
couldn't stop watching it i'm not gonna
say it's not necessarily
a great movie like the imd rating it got
5.8 out of 10.
uh i'm not even sure what the rotten
tomato score is of this movie
but it was very
interesting
it's very interesting man you know um so
the lie opens up with
this young girl and her mom
you know and you you they established
that the mom's seeing someone new and
this isn't her dad
and the mom's seeing someone new and she
has a contentious relationship with her
daughter
and then they go meet the dad
now the girl is about to go to some
ballet camp for this for like a week
and then she's fighting with the mom i
don't want to go so you're already kind
of establishing that they're not they're
not close but she's a teenager it's
teenage [ __ ] right so they go pick up
the dad who the little girl obviously
loves it's one of those situations where
mom's the villain and dad's the great
guy and you could se and the guy he's
seeing someone else too and the mom's
meeting this girl for the first time and
so the little girl gets in the car with
the dad and she's like oh mom didn't
know you told me not to tell her you
know that kind of thing and so he the
dad's gonna take her to the camp
so they're driving in this like snowy
road and they're passing like a bus stop
but it's one of these like country road
bus stops and the little girl sees her
friend
and she's like oh dad pull over it's
britney
you know so they pick brittany up
and brittany's a little
they they got they playing her like
she's a little [ __ ] even though she's a
little young 16 year old so she's all
flirting with the dad you know what i
mean she's like oh mr sun
you know and you're just kind of like
what's going on right
so then the girls are like they got to
go to the bathroom but they on a country
road because he's taking them to some
camp so they're on this country road
right
so then they pull over
they pull over on the country road and
the little girls jump out of the car and
they run into the woods because they're
going to go pee
time is going by and the dad's like
where the hell these girls at so he goes
looking for them he says kayla the
girl's name's kayla he's like where are
you
so then he gets to like a bridge over
some water it's like a bridge over like
a little stream but it's kind of it's
not like a deep but it's like you could
tell it's like the water is moving okay
he's like where's your friend where's
your friend and a little girl has got
like a she's just sitting there like in
shock on the bridge she's like sitting
on the bridge in shock like on the
railing and the dad's like what are you
doing and he's like where's your friend
and then
the girl starts crying and she's like i
pushed her
we were fighting so the little girl
tells her father that she pushed her
friend into the lake
okay into this like freezing cold
whatever
the dad freaks out he runs down to the
thing he's like why did you join us and
he's looking for the girl he's like
brand name
and he's like looking for her looking
for her looking for and then he can't
find her he can't find her now he's in a
panic he grabs his little girl they get
in the car and they bounce
you hear what i said
they don't look for the little girl
anymore they don't call the cops they
bounce
the dad is like it was an accident and
then the girl freaks out and she's like
it wasn't an accident i did it on
purpose
i pushed her on purpose because she was
a [ __ ] so you're like what
the little girl 15 16 murders her friend
pushes her into the water and takes off
so now the dad's in a panic
so he's like
you know
the little girl
they see they find the girl's purse it's
a little pink purse and the phone is in
it so they grab the little girl grabs
the purse dad don't know all right now
they head back to the city because they
got to go tell mom
so they pull up to mom's job she's a
lawyer and the mom's like mad at him
because he's like what are you doing why
why didn't you take her you always do
this it's that kind of like so you know
this kind of [ __ ] happens all the time
where the dad don't take care of
business so he's trying to talk to her
and she won't listen right so then they
take her home and the girl's kind of
like the girl's freaking out a little
bit
so then they get home and the parents
are kind of going at it and then the
little girl disappears from the room and
she goes she's in now she jumps into a
bath and the mom's in there like what
are you doing and the dad's like trying
to tell her mom like yo we gotta talk
[ __ ] like you need to listen to me and
so she's like he he comes into the
bathroom and he's like let me just take
her home with me you know i'm gonna take
it he's the mom's like get out of here
so then like
you know they do this thing where the
door closes you see the dad down the
hallway with nervousness and then and
then the mom comes out like
flabbergasted and you know the little
girl told the mom
so now they out here like what do we do
and it made me think like what would you
do your little girl
your teenage girl
basically
accidentally or maybe not accidentally
murder somebody
okay
so now the parents are like they they in
a quandary because they're like what are
we gonna do she's a lawyer and the dad's
like what are you gonna like you know
and the mom you could tell the mom is
kind of sick of her daughter like in the
sense of like but that's just natural
it's like your parent you have a
teenager
they're getting on your nerves teenagers
are [ __ ] and she's just over it but
now it's like boom is she a good person
or not so now the mom's like what are we
supposed to do and the dad's like we to
cover this up basically that's the thing
we can't just we you know nobody knows
we were there that's what he says no one
knows we were there let's not worry
about it
britney's dad shows up
just brittany's dad's like he calls
first and he's like hey
you know
the girls are doing some nonsense again
you know they didn't show up to the camp
okay so he's thinking that the girls are
together and they off doing some teenage
stuff and the girl didn't show up to the
camp so there this parents are like well
no actually kayla's with us she uh
she was sick
so now the dad's like what and now the
dad's thinking oh man i cuz he didn't
drive her to the camp the dad was
punishing his daughter and made her
sit on a go take the bus
by the way brittany the other girl she
had like a bruise on her chin that's
important for the story later
so now the dad is all like he's starting
to be like well okay maybe she's
punished me and the girl britney has run
away before so second time running away
she's already run away two other times
okay so now the parents are like well no
kayla's with us now the dad is like well
i need to talk to her does she know
where britney is
and these parents are like
yo
no she's at the doctor you know uh
they're trying they don't want the dad
to talk to the daughter
okay
they don't want the dad to talk now the
other girl is sort of freaking out now
she's like am i a horrible person and
she's acting all like
batshit and she also has like an inhaler
okay so she has to take an inhaler and
you also find out that she's been
cutting so she's the kind of girl that
she's not popular she's like whatever
you know she's got some issues okay so
they say to the dad we taking her to we
took her to the doctor she went with the
doctor with the dad so now that dad's
trying to be like yo
he can't find his daughter
so he keeps calling
he's calling like yo
i need to talk to your daughter because
i can't find my daughter and they're
best friends and they have to know
what's going on
all right so then dad shows up again and
the dad's like hey how can you not
return to my calls and the mom was like
yeah well you know she's at the doctor
but then the dad comes out the house
hey what's going on and then the other
dad's like
wait where's your daughter you left her
at the doctor's office by herself
and then
you know they're they're kind of like oh
yeah yeah we're gonna go get her they
they trip it and then the girl the
stupid little girl comes out the house
too and he's like what's going on now
the dad is like why are you lying
you told me that your daughter was at
the hospital they like what's going on
i'm going to the cops so now they now
they like messed up
you know i would have
i don't know
i'm not advocating
corporal punishment with your kids
but
you know
stay in the house [ __ ] you know what i
mean
you don't murder somebody are you out
here in these streets
all right
so now they're in a panic okay so now
they're trying to decide oh by the way
the other other dad he's very aggressive
you know like aggressive like
you know he
is trying to like get to the girl and
they're like get off and he punches the
dad so now they're like get the hell out
of here so now he's aggressive so now
they're in the house and they having a
discussion about
maybe we should frame
the dad that's basically the discussion
of like well maybe you know he probably
hits her she had a bruise
and you know so now the mom is like what
so now my daughter killed a girl and now
we gonna frame the dad
but she doesn't she used to work in the
prosecutor's office and so she goes and
talks to a prosecutor friend of hers the
cops she used to work in that so she was
like the she was like the she was like
the prosecutor so she goes and talks to
one of the investigative cops it kind of
reveals like hey
this dad was acting strange all right so
now these two cops go talk to the dad
they're going to talk to the dad now and
they like and so it's very contentious
at first
you know
but then the cops come back to the house
and they like yeah
um
so
what happened
because now they've talked to neighbors
and they get a different sense of who
this guy is
so then they go and by the way yeah we
uh we track brittany's phone
and it's actually in downtown doesn't
your husband live in downtown
so now
the mom was like what
because the little girl took the purse
from the water
so now
the husband the the
dad
he finally goes back to his house he's
in a band and his band is there waiting
for him and he's dating one of the girls
in the band and she's all like where you
been
we're supposed to be practicing this is
important and then she's like this whose
purse is this i found this in your car
she's basically being like what [ __ ]
who else are you having sex you know and
now the dad's like why is that purse
here so he gets the purse from her so
now he looks in the purse and then the
phone
he okay so now they're in a panic so now
they go back
so now their police investigators are
now they're like
the dad tells them so they they they go
to this country road bus stop
and now they like what the hell is going
on
okay so now they go back to the house
and they interview the parents now
they're interviewing these two parents
and they're like hey
um
did you were you guys on a bridge you
know and the dad already lied he said no
i picked her up she wasn't feeling well
we went right to my we went right
downtown you know and they said are you
sure
and then giving them the opportunity
and then the cop pulls out an inhaler
because we found your daughter's inhaler
at the bridge
not a gig's up okay
so now the mom is like get out she kicks
the cops out
so now they're in a panic
so now the parents are like what the
hell do we do
so they make another dumb choice
they go in the middle of the night to
the dad's the the father of the the dead
girl they go
and then they take the phone and purse
and the dad's in the backyard and he
tries to
dig a hole and he's gonna put the purse
and the phone in this hole by the dad's
house
to try to
maybe the dad hit it type of thing right
it's ridiculous
but then the dad comes out
and he confronts them both
and he's like
i know you're because the dad actually
got the other little girl alone walking
on the street and she starts to like she
cracks because she ain't [ __ ] you know
she's all like
i didn't mean for this to go this far
and but he's like what are you talking
about what are you talking about so he
freaks out she has a panic attack with
her inhaler so they find her on the
ground in the house and they're like
what the hell's wrong with you so now
that everybody's in a panic and that's
why they go to put the thing so the dad
comes out and he gets into a squabble
with the father the other father and the
father beats him up and he's like almost
drowns him you know and then they take
off and then the dad's running after
them and he kind of crosses over and
he's in the street and the dad's like
you know he's like stop and the mom
runs this dude over
so they crash into him he's in the
middle of the street
and they let him die
so they murdered the father
so now they're back at the house
and they clean in the car because
there's blood on the thing and they
trying to cover up this crime
and maybe they think they'll make it so
the dad disappears and they don't have
to worry about it
and then in walks
brittany
the dead girl
she ain't dead y'all
she's like hi
i'm so sorry it's kayla here i made her
do it you know it was my fault i just
wanted to spend time with my boyfriend
they lied
the whole time
the little girl's alive
and the parents
are looking at her like
what
you're alive
and then the mom says to her
no you can't talk to her
you should go home
and then the two parents walk into the
room and they go like looking at her
like
what the [ __ ]
and the little girl she breaks down
she's like it wasn't my fault brittany
made me do it and i was gonna tell you
guys but then you guys were laughing and
because they were divorced
and so the two parents
they
were going because of this trauma they
were going to each other for support and
help
and that's what they did so the little
girl was like i wanted to keep it going
because of what it was doing for us we
were happy again
and then she was like don't leave me you
know and then and the parents are in
shock
they hug the daughter
and the movie ends with the three of
them hugging
and you hear police sirens
wow
i was looking i was just thinking to
myself
they murdered the father
because their little girl was a little
liar in life
what
so
anyway y'all
[Laughter]
that's the freaking lie
you know i usually have my usual outro
song but you know what today let's get
let's outro with one of chris hughes
songs
uh anyways guys i really appreciate you
watching riffing with griffin
uh that's today's episode
shout out to chris you i'm putting i'm
gonna put his instagram in the uh
the chat coming up with these great
beats
uh make sure you subscribe
share
follow
hit me up on twitch air griffin gaming
why ain't nobody came to help me you
know what i mean so make sure you guys
come on out every week
here on riffing with griffin
oh yeah
richard griffin
always riffing
telling everybody about it
shout it out
scotty body
scooty back
this is how we do it
every day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks y'all
see you next week